tu crois quoi il est question dans mon
jardin je vais tenter à l'intérieur il
faut retirer
non mais c'est d'abord ça du putois la
perm et toi tu t'emmerdes à kaunas dans
cette famille oui c'est qui le plus beau
bébé du goûter le petit enzo il se passe
quelque chose de paranormal je te dis
que je ressens une présence dans cette
maison vide hunt et du bruit aucune
raison façon d'enrayer l'activité laine
folder expert en surnaturel je vais
devoir emprunter certains de vos effets
personnels d'accord question d'y
détecter des résidus de démence ou de
fantômes vous nous dévalisés et aimant
contrôler mon point sera d'élucider le
mystère elle est vraiment au fond des
choses
vous êtes à la recherche d'une
extraction de rêve ce tube va dans votre
bouche et celui ci dans votre rectum
ça y est il est rentré attendez je
m'excuse celui là va dans la bouche et
c'est l'autre qui va donc mais comment
c'est qu'il a sorti un racing qui est-ce
qui vous veut du mal on fait quoi
maintenant ballon dans un foyer on m'a
dit qu'il y ait de sortir qu'il veut du
mal il ya toujours une ballerine qui
veut s'accaparer les projecteurs
j'ai fait le lac des cygnes quand
j'étais enceinte de toi ceci est une
insulte à la danse classique assez nul à
chier j'ai trouvé des vidéos de sécurité
que laisse penser une propriétaire ont
laissé ça pourrait peut-être nous en
apprendre beaucoup dit ça j-pr line the
cherry je te jure que tu n'as pas
attaquer c'est pas ça qui va m'arrêter